Marvel finally gave us a new trailer for
a spider-man far from home and compared
to the initial tease it really sets up a
post endgame MCU Vic is from Earth just
not Alice the snap to our hole in our
dimension yes that's exactly what the
trailer is saying in the Marvel Comics
there exists the multiverse it's a way
to tell alternate stories about
characters you're already familiar with
that diverge from the main Marvel
continuity but it doesn't affect the
main Marvel continuity basically the
multiverse is a way of creating and
working with ongoing alternate realities
think of each reality as its own
universe with its own timeline put them
together and their the multiverse if you
saw a Spiderman into the spider-verse
you're already familiar with the concept
each universe has its own quirks with
its own heroes sometimes there are
overwhelming similarities but usually
there are huge differences for example
the Marvel Universe in the comics is
referred to as earth-616 this is the one
that has existed for 80 years and aside
from the MCU it's the one that most
people are familiar with but if a
creator wants to tell a different story
say one where Charles Xavier is murdered
at a young age causing a chain reaction
that sees the villain apocalypse conquer
almost the entire world then an
alternate universe is needed give it a
number in this case earth to 95 and
you're good to go tell your story do
whatever you want to the characters and
none of it should affect the main
timeline but more on that later
now time travel can and does play a part
in these realities the x-men are
constantly traveling through time to
avert possible disaster whether it's
from sentinels in the legendary Days of
Future past story or in the more recent
old man Logan both storylines took place
and dystopian futures with x-men from
present-day earth-616 but the future
events of Days of Future past took place
on earth 8:11 while the future events of
old man Logan took place on earth eight
hundred seven thousand one hundred
twenty eight it's a way of working with
characters you already know and love
while adding all sorts
twists turns and alternate takes hey I
know they later change old man Logan to
not be the x-men were all familiar with
but we'll save retroactive continuity
for another video now remember that part
about characters from other timelines
not affecting the main timeline well
that actually gets a little complicated
if a character or something else from an
alternate reality as a hit say the
extremely evil version of beast from the
Age of Apocalypse the MIL usually
somehow cross through time and space to
wind up in the mean Marvel reality
earth-616 characters from one reality
can and do cross over to other realities
all the time one comic the Exiles sees
characters from various realities come
together as a team
to hop from one reality to another
averting disaster and correcting huge
mistakes in the timeline every single
one of their missions could be
considered a time heist were you asking
yourself how Captain America didn't
screw up the timeline at the end of
endgame he probably did there's a good
chance him staying behind in the past
created a whole new dimension of reality
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe is
referred to as Earth 190 9999 he could
have gone back and stayed behind in what
would become say Earth 300 mm 481 he
would have had to cross over to the main
MCU reality to bring Sam the shield but
he just kind of appears on that bench at
the end of endgame so it is possible the
Russo brothers have been pretty adamant
this cat came from another dimension
and since there exists a team of heroes
whose job it is to fix mistakes in the
timeline it may be possible we'll see
the reality hopping exiles on the big
screen Marvel could be setting up the
multiverse as a way to bring the
Avengers the x-men and the Fantastic
Four all together on the big screen
having each team inhabit its own reality
would explain why they've never run into
each other before and it would also
explain why say the x-men didn't help
defeat Thanos now there's a lot of other
stuff that goes along with the
multiverse it's too complicated to get
in here but you should know that Merlin
yes that Merlin or his daughter Roma
generally serves as the protector of the
multiverse
the x-men offshoot team Excalibur is
very linked to the multiverse and Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four is
constantly building transporters to jump
through time and hop dimensions so the
potential is there to bring the teams
together this way I'm not saying that's
how they'll do it but after introducing
the concept of time travel in endgame
and bringing in the multiverse in far
from home it's clear Marvel has decided
one universe isn't enough to play with
they're going for infinity you think you
know how the world works this doesn't
make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to